c'est moi Barbie Harfleur vous êtes bien
assis je conseille les morts pour les
aider à passer de l'autre côté on
pourrait penser que c'est lourd de voir
des morts mais franchement ça me pèse
bien moins que le lieu de torture dans
lequel je suis obligé de passer mes
journées
le lycée
une pomme pomme girl de légende et il
faut être bête et joli non merci pour ta
question et je te répondrai que cette
offensant Caprice est très bien que sur
moi elle n'a aucune influence Barbie
qu'est-ce que tu fais là
mes vêtements pourquoi je les aurais
pris je sais pas d'enterrement
aujourd'hui
capitaine de l'équipe des cheerleaders
tu me vois qu'est-ce que tu fais là ma
fête d'anniversaire est dans un mois tu
peux m'aider et tu auras la paix après
je partirai tu vis sur quelle planète tu
crois vraiment qu'on va m'écouter sur
une planète où je ferai de toi une fille
populaire
c'est trop jalouse je veux ces fesses
tout le monde parle de moi
on n'est jamais préparé
connaît quand même que je suis doué
[Musique]